what's up everybody welcome to another
YouTube hangout super excited to be here
I've got a special guest with me Vinnie
Fisher from fully accountable calm and
we're going to be talking about how to
break through to the next level Vinnie
welcome aboard man hey thanks for having
man that's really exciting so a little
bit of context just for my audience if
you can tell them quickly
who's Vinnie Fisher what you're
passionate about what you're up to so
they get a little background on you yeah
so many Fisher is a serial entrepreneur
I've actually successfully grown for
eight figure businesses sold two of them
broke one of them
the other one is currently running
thankfully so I understand a business at
a high level I'm a lawyer by training
I've had you know I probably put 300
million through the door over the last
eight years so we've had some good runs
you know and we right now we have a
company called fully accountable as you
mentioned where we come alongside
accounting professionals and really
equip the small business to be able to
understand the finance of their business
of it so we're talking about getting
through the next level what do you think
is holding people back what are some of
the common challenges that you've seen
yourself and your senior clients that
they need help breaking through you know
I'll tell you you know it scares people
but like I wrote a book called the CEOs
mindset and I talked about it in there a
lot and that's not a plug for the book
cause I'll just tell your whole tribe
about it right now but you know in it's
literally and from my bias you know I've
had 2,000 employees maybe now I'm over
that now it's all about teaming you
cannot do this alone
we have a rockstar executive team around
us and it's because I've invested in it
I'm the chief evangelist of our company
and where I see the major roadblock in
businesses is not continually investing
in maturing your team you know what are
the killers of businesses the killers of
businesses are easy you're selling your
product to the wrong market or you got
the wrong product in the right market
that's easy I can solve that problem the
next one is your cash flow sucks because
you keep blowing it on marketing spend
that just but invariably if you are
continually to work on
good people surrounded you you can work
through those problems and so to me I
will always always be advocating you got
to continue to top grade your team so
there's a great book out there about top
grading right and people are like oh my
gosh I can't fire people no but you can
help mature them or move them into
positions they don't want to be heeled
we don't talk enough in small businesses
about the true heartbeat in the true
harpy is you and I man we're the owners
of our companies and the heartbeat is it
like this cultural Apple thing where
there's thousands of employees in the
small American business which makes up
almost 50% of the payroll daily in this
country you and I are its harpy and if
our heartbeat doesn't line up with our
team we're gonna have a heart attack and
that's what kills most businesses and
their ability to continue to excel and
double over on time so for let's go like
early days for the startup entrepreneur
you know solopreneur they're trying to
hire the first person yeah a lot of
first hires don't work out you know they
hire the wrong person they don't know
how to manage somebody yeah and you know
they end up letting that person go and
they say I'm never gonna hire anybody
again I'm gonna do it on myself because
I'm gonna get it done on time it's gonna
be perfect in my way you know what do
you see to that entrepreneur you know I
guess I'd say to that entrepreneur did
you have a girlfriend or boyfriend
before did you give up on dating just
because you dated the wrong person the
first time I like that you know Ari or
did you decide never to get married
because you had a bad girlfriend or did
you work through that and so first off
I'd help with the mental block that
you're gonna strike out when you know in
baseball Ted Williams made the Hall of
Fame batting 343 that means he's struck
out 60% or didn't hit get a hit almost
70% of the time and so that's employee
stuff man like we can get all
complicated about how to do it right
I'll tell you the other thing that's the
problem is you look that first employee
the wrong way you and I have an
expertise we're like naturally good at
something for me it's sales and
marketing I'm just really good at it
like it's just what I like to do and
come out of the egg with the ability to
do that I can blow things up because I
understand consumer behavior what I
discovered over time is this the
hardest thing for me to delegate in my
business but what happens with us
solopreneurs when we're back down there
is we've the first thing we try to do is
get rid of that work and give it to
somebody and it's the most impossible
task to do because you can't train
something with that you just innately do
it's like how do you train something you
don't even know why you're able to be
good at it's your natural given talent
so when I say to the solopreneurs is
make sure your hire is actually
correctly targeted on a high need for
your business then is it starting with
your core expertise go backfill
something you're not the expert at
that's critical to moving the company
because then here's what happens Evan
let's talk about it back when I was
younger in my business the first thing
everyone does is hire a secretary I
guess we call them an admin now right to
be socially correct and that's a
disaster too because go do my laundry go
do this like you're not doing anything
to move the needle of the company so I
asked solopreneurs look in your business
and what is what's missing if you could
duplicate yourself that's going to be a
needle mover and start there and the
only qualifier I put on that is it can't
be your expertise it has to be something
else and then you talked about
leadership skills and so a lot of times
when people are hiring they're only
looking for the skills right okay listen
to Vinnie I hired the person you know I
need a programmer I'm going to hire that
programmer it's the biggest need but I'm
just treating them like somebody who's
pushing out code and I'm actually being
a leader you know where do we how do we
start to learn leadership skills because
we don't go to class for we haven't
learned it in our schools you know we
may not have learned it growing up from
our parents so if there's an
entrepreneur who may not be you know
have the history of being a leader but
now I recognize I need to lead my team
and not choose treat them like
somebody's punching out code what where
do I start what advice do you have so
you know I I would say it starts with
this do you just want to be a
solopreneur or do you actually want to
grow something I think you got to start
there because if you really just want to
be a solopreneur don't whine and scream
about not the ability to manage people
if that's all you really want then one
that if you want more leaders are built
they're not born and since that's
happening the wisdom and trial of life
helps a ton I would certainly be
absorbing information from people who've
been
successful at it it certainly would be
seeking guidance from women and men who
have struck out majorly figuring out how
to lead other people but for me and it
starts with like golden rule stuff right
my faith is important to me so I try to
actually treat someone the way I want to
be treated
I've also as a solopreneur back early
days for a while I'm older now I'm
thankful not that BNF situation but it
occurred to me I just gave us advice to
a friend the other day that we are so
annoyed that someone doesn't know as
much as we know so we have we get we
forget how much we really know and how
long it took us to be an expert at what
we do whether it's a funnel builder
traffic guy or you know we you and I
live in the digital world right so we
just know so many digital people and
that's where we make the majority of our
living the average person out there has
no idea what the Freak we do like early
days in my hosting company people are
like what do you do sell porn like
what's up like you just don't know the
business model and that's true of your
employees there's you know we believe in
hiring culture over talent you got to
have a minimum set to be a programmer
right Evan and so in order to do that I
say you got to have a little longer
leash and a tolerance to train somebody
and not be annoyed that they don't know
as much as you do our one into their job
of it I'm really curious about your
journey from from being a lawyer to
going into sales and marketing as as
your passion because it's not typically
the skills that you see in lawyers but
what I want to hit up a couple live
questions first do it um so darshan is
asking how do I get out of my comfort
zone so what do you recommend for
entrepreneurs to get out of the comfort
zone you know you got to do something
uncomfortable every day so I walked
onstage at a big event irrelevant what
it is and I went and laid down on the
floor just came out got announced that
went lay down on the floor for a minute
it got awkward social weird and someone
asked me and then my speech was about
get out of your comfort zone do little
stuff like just last week I was with my
kids and I was trying to show them the
example of how to stretch herself so I
laid down in the middle of a cold stone
while people are walking by us
and I jokingly said why don't I just do
a snow angel it doesn't have to be like
you go try to do something you're not an
expert at but I found and if you can
stretch yourself in socially awkward
situations you start to realize that you
should you care less about what other
people think and the reason why what
holds us back I could remember our
person's name but um the reason why that
holds us back is we care too much about
what people think and if we stopped and
realize how much they don't think about
us then we would probably stop thinking
less about what they really think about
us and I've learned in socially awkward
situations it helps a ton with that so
so it was darshan who is asking and so
it's an easy thing to say and lots of
people say it how do you actually then
go about applying it so you know you're
afraid to start a YouTube channel
because of how people might judge you
how do you recognize that fear and then
have the courage to push through it yeah
so I to me I serve a principle called
progress not perfection
and the problem is most of us have a
vision of how we want something to look
and the firt like if you guys if your
tribe went and just looked up Vinnie
Fisher in my original YouTube channel
you'll see these videos where I'm like
uh well uh and I look terrible and I've
left them up there on purpose because it
was the first version and you know it's
funny one of those videos get ridiculous
amounts of views and it was good
substance but I was staring at the
camera freaked out of my mind and I've
been a professional speaker I've been on
stage I had just never done it and I
would say you just turn the freaking
camera on you press the button and you
do it
and you accept the first version a
friend of mine says version done is
better than version perfect right or
however he says it but to me I serve a
God of progress over perfection there's
only one perfect solution and if you
look at any of my stuff we're always
iterating I get it out there you want
our brain actually doesn't want to be
criticized it's actually the best thing
that could happen to you is to get
criticized because you want that
feedback to make it better so shut that
front part of your brain off that's
afraid out of their mind of getting
criticized it's the healthiest thing
to grow your business this criticism
because too many people have money and
blow it the broke people should be the
ones who kill it because the only thing
you have to do is turn the button on and
accept the criticism and listen to a
little bit of the haters listen to what
they're saying and tweak and get better
and laugh at yourself don't take
yourself so stinkin seriously an old fat
bald guy like this can't be too serious
about life but people need to hear what
you're talking about so screw up screw
up a bunch and keep going forward I'll
tell you man that if people just
believed you because I've watched
yourself if they just believed that and
they just did that kind of stuff they
just took the chance I'll tell you they
will feel fulfilled just by doing it I
love it Vinny's Vinny's bringing the
fire today
we had a lot of it man that's great uh
okay next one Evan please ask Vinnie how
to break through your limiting personal
beliefs who first I think you have to
start yeah Evan it was in heaven who's
that his name uh Iceland as well I like
it has a good name so I think the first
thing is I don't think we work enough
but self-awareness how do you even know
what those limiting beliefs are like
unless you sit down like every day man I
sit down with my journal
right and I'm write notes and I'm
listening to you know the spirit and
what's happening inside of me what am i
what am I actually responding to what am
i freaked out about is there enough
money in the bank account whatever that
junk is there is like this seventh grade
version of ourselves with this really
bad roommate in our head who's always
talking us out of things and like how do
you shut that roommate up and unless you
know we're all different right man you
have some issues I have some issues and
so I know what they are about me I could
rattle them off right now because I'm
actually paying attention to those so
once you know once you actually have a
better understanding a little bit about
yourself then it's actually the hard
work the hard work starts then right how
do you shut him up man every day every
day this roommate in my head you know I
always joke and say imagine having a
dating coach then acted like the
roommate in your head
she didn't call me back fast enough all
you know what I would do I would just
give up man
don't don't call her that just you just
wait man she doesn't like you too you'd
fire that coach in a second but we give
that coach in our head we go right back
the next day and go man
you were right I'm so glad I listened to
all that crap well that's what we do in
our life man we do our business we do
that our marriage we do that our
business partnerships we do that in the
way we think about customers we get in
our own head and so I would say the
people who practice quieting down the
noise in their head are the ones I've
noticed including myself of the most
successful at it I love it for the
journaling thing what's your process I'm
curious is that a daily habit in the
morning evening is there structure
around and what do you what do you do
for journaling and has it helped yeah so
for me it's important you know I have a
daily habit of just getting in the word
for me every day it's important to me
and from that I will then sit down for
probably no less than 15 but almost
closer to 30 minutes and in write and
I'll write notes
it's what's led to me having three books
it's what's led to me continually
putting out content so I've developed a
habit of reflection and notes and I'll
tell you that's so much more important
to me than exercise and all these other
things that I make sure I demand it's in
my calendar interesting interesting
I like it um okay next question someone
is asking back to your reference about
leadership can be trained he wants to
know your opinion on winners being born
or not so Gary Vaynerchuk apparently
says winners are born at least according
to this guy so what what are you what
are your thoughts on that winners being
born or made so I came from a very
broken family and you know my parents
never made above 30 something thousand
dollars in their job very poor very
broke and my dad lived a lifer we grew
he's dead now we lived a life of regret
and I can talk about this stuff he
always looked at the wood as sure to cut
up my dad basically always looked at
life as it was its blame and it owed him
something so I wasn't born a winner I'll
tell you the reason why Gary's off on
that in the Ritz he's just telling a
sexy message I've actually had the
privilege and I'm cursed
we friendly with gear I had him on one
of my things you know I could go spend
time with them Gary's just trying to get
an emotional charge out of you the
reality is that there's all kinds of
crap that happens if people say and do
to you that can actually frame who you
are it's a conscious decision to decide
the opposite of that so look let's just
pick another sports analogy you know Tom
Landry this old-time coach from the
Cowboys and Vince Lombardi couldn't have
any different personalities if it was
possible and they both won the Superbowl
it's something that's that's why if you
have a bunch of garbage in your head
surround yourself with people who
literally think more abundant who
actually look at life as a blessing and
an opportunity and are on a journey to
try to be better than they were where
they were yesterday if you're literally
looking backwards yesterday discouraged
and you're not like wow my lungs are
filling with air holy cow the Sun showed
back up again today and you're not
having a blessings or gratefulness
attitude then you're going to believe
that crap that only the people who were
born with a winning attitude are going
to succeed and that's just a bunch of
crap I like it yeah Lee Stanley is next
uh Vinnie what's the book you're
currently reading oh you know I just
read it's right here I just finished it
yesterday it's called never split the
difference oh yeah I'm Chris Voss FBI
negotiator guy yeah solid book but what
I read before this that I would highly
recommend to people is called leadership
and self deception okay but I've just
read this never split the difference now
I think mostly like this book so
actually I'm getting closer here I've
stalked him we're gonna be friends but
we I love with he talks about here he
talks about this idea of the noise in
your head and when we go into
everything's in negotiation so you asked
me earlier about wow how do you go from
a lawyer to a salesman in a marketer I
actually think it might have been the
wrong question how do the sales and
marketer get trained into being a lawyer
right right because really I run my
lawyer friends everything I'm not a
lawyers lawyer I'm strategic I think big
picture
I'll give you advice on how to take risk
not avoid it so I'm probably not your
prototypical lawyer whose job is
tell you how to avoid risk that's the
job of a lawyer right I show you how to
navigate it so I'm not necessarily was
designed to be the prototypical type
lawyer and so with that in mind I love
how he says in here
don't let patterns of caring about what
other people think define on how you
approach things right and so this is a
definite read I'm going to tell you this
is probably gonna be a top five for me
I'll tell you I haven't as part of
reading Oh too many people read too many
books now I probably read about 40 to 50
books a year I probably pull off close
to one a week with that set
I repeat books more than I'm always
looking to go read more books and in
addition to that I think there's seasons
of your life of things you should be
reading about so right now I am consumed
with human behavior and the mindset of
how we all are emotional a mess full of
baggage and it's because of that that we
actually can have ability to really
properly communicate tell each other
stuff and help each other and so that's
just my season like when I was younger
and I didn't know I might have read a
whole bunch of leadership books and I
did and but I'm just not reading those
now because that I'm in a season of life
where I'm probable they're a little
different things I'm looking at and so
I'll be very careful as a reader to be
not all over the place look at the
season you're in of what you need to be
equipped with read there and so by the
way knowledge is only 1/2 the equation
to power the other half to that power is
execution so if I read those 40 or 50
books and I didn't do squat with those
books that I'm a freaking loser
I have no power I don't mean to be
offensive I'll try to use less offensive
words but reading means nothing unless
you put it into action
so the my job is to now leave my
executive team and pull out the Nuggets
in here and equip them and understand
where they're not negotiating correctly
top 5 of all time all right I mean I
really like this cat I've heard of it
and I've seen I do some interviews and
we did I think a video on him but I
haven't read the book so Dom it's a good
nugget there um maybe this ties into
your story so next question is Francois
is asking was there a specific memory or
moment that became the turning point in
your life you know I I come from a very
broken background open to talk about I
wrote I've read about it so I'm not
afraid to talk about it I am I realized
early on that this was a bad habit the
beginning of my life man I realized it
was all me and if I didn't pull up the
bootstraps and go do it myself then it
wasn't gonna get done and so I lived
that first part of my life now I look
back I blew our first business the
hosting company we're doing about 40
million a year in revenue and I was
arrogant enough to believe we're going
to turn to the 80 million revenue I turn
down a letter of intent didn't sell it
handed the reins off to a CEO that CEO
crashed and burned it I then had to pull
it back
sold it for parts made a little bit of
money the gold tooth phone totally got
damaged and I wrote about losing 30
million dollars and it's true it's real
and my old business partner from time to
time when we don't cry about it laugh
about it move on but what I was trying
to explain in that is it had a shift in
my head I'm like holy cow why am I
trying to do this alone why am I not
seeking people who are a few steps ahead
of me and they're available what do
people like to talk about the most Evan
themselves exactly so why not go talk to
successful guys and ask them how they
got there so I changed my thing so my
rolodex is filled with millionaires and
a few billionaires who are ahead of me
and I'm can even like it fully
accountable I am continually out there
speaking to Mavericks who are ahead of
me in software so I've struck a
friendship up with some Intuit people
and I'm chasing down the guy from mint
and why because I convinced it into its
going to buy our software and so why not
ask them exactly how it's done so that
when this time friend of bias that I've
already been CD seeking counsel
counseling and mentoring for them so
this whole idea of do it alone man it
was I was trying to like prove everybody
wrong I just chip on my shoulder because
I heard this crap that was from this
family you can't do it now kicked your
coverage did it so I'm like well screw
all you I'm just going to show you I can
do it now my mission is to be pointing
to the front row of my life
and point and say I would have done it
without that guy that girl help me that
girl that guy and I want to give all of
them the credit because I realized man
you try to go out this alone it's
freaking lonely I love it well I
appreciate the honesty and passion and
fire you bring every question it's
awesome
you know we're bumping up against the
clock here or maybe on that last note
can you tell us a little bit more but
fully countable what you're doing how it
helps entrepreneurs how might be
relevant for my audience yeah so you
know it started as a full-service
outsourced accounting right so
everything from bookkeeper to CFO along
the way we realized some big things
about the business so we would fill in
one of those holes for a company but we
thought that everyone thinks they have
one of those accounting professionals so
we built for our own internal actual
software that runs the back office of
the business to optimize our accounting
professionals and then we launched that
to the world
so we actually help small businesses run
a finance department not just put your
QuickBooks stuff in there but actually a
benchmark to metrics to really analyze
cash flow make real decisions so you can
actually do something in your business
and our mission is to double the size of
a hundred thousand companies and the
only way we were going to get there is
to equip more small business accounting
professionals with the tools to do that
and you know we're on a really fun
growth curve making that happen create
predictable cash flow which is the
number two reason why businesses fail
we're trying to stop that problem very
cool well guys you can check that out
fully accountable com will link it up
with the description as well uh Vinnie
one minute left
your final message to wrap all of this
stuff up final message for my audience
what do you got you know I would
encourage everybody even to stop and
look at who you are are you someone
that's more focused on the future what
you don't have because you didn't work
hard enough to get it are you someone
who laments on the past know who you are
you a past self or a future self because
that's important as to the decisions you
make so I realized I'm always a future
person I find if I have a goal to lose
25 pounds and I lose 20 I would look at
myself as a failure instead of
celebrating that I got 20 of it done and
so I had to start learning how to be way
real right now enjoy my family enjoy our
business and
be so discouraged it's not the size I
want it to be for a past version person
that means stop defining yourself what
didn't work don't look at your failures
as a our identity and I would encourage
you everybody if you stop and look at
that you're going to find out you what
your respect level is the time and once
you go on that journey I'd encourage you
to have a much longer perspective value
evaluate time I love it Vinnie Fisher
everyone go follow me on Twitter check
out fully accountable calm Vinnie really
appreciate the time today man thanks
brother